-Enjoy yourself.
Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome,
welcome to "The Tonight Show."
You're here. You're watching.
"The Tonight Show" is on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey, this is exciting.
I want to say
congratulations to Disney
for celebrating their
100th anniversary today.
[ Cheers and applause ]
100.
And to celebrate 100 years,
ironically, pricing on Disney+
went from Goofy status
to this is ducking insane.
[ Laughter ]
Of course, Disneyland's slogan
is the happiest place on Earth.
It's not to be confused with
the slogan for Busch Gardens --
"technically a place on Earth,"
and you go, well, it is.
[ Laughter ]
Well, get this. Rite Aid
just filed for bankruptcy
and could be closing more than
2,000 of their stores.
Yeah, it's amazing
that their business model
of just being a crappier
CVS didn't pan out.
[ Laughter ]
But they actually pressed
the button for help weeks ago,
but no one noticed until now.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, Jada Pinkett Smith
said that they were bankrupt
seven years ago
but just didn't tell anyone.
It's interesting.
[ Audience oohs ]
[ Rimshot ]
You could tell that they were
going out of business
when they just relabeled Tums
as Halloween candy.
You go, "That's it."
You could tell that they were
going out of business
when you asked the pharmacist
what he had for pain,
and he handed you
his bottle of Cuervo.
[ Laughter ]
Some news from Washington.
The House is coming up
on two weeks without a speaker,
and tomorrow Republicans
plan to hold a vote.
If the House can't
elect a speaker,
the Constitution says
that it will be decided
by the judges
on "The Masked Singer."
[ Laughter ]
The speaker is now Disco Pickle.
Now, Republicans and Democrats
are talking about a bipartisan
solution to finding a speaker.
That's how crazy things
have gotten.
Our government
is so dysfunctional
it might become functional.
[ Laughter ]
Well, some huge political news.
In his new biography,
Senator Mitt Romney
says that back in 2020,
Oprah suggested that they run
for president
together to keep former
president Trump out of office.
Wow.
If you thought Dr. Fauci was
confused, imagine Dr. Phil.
"Of all the chicks
in the henhouse
trying to lay a golden egg,
and you're on the wrong side
of the beaver dam."
Can I go outside or...?
When he heard about
Romney and Oprah,
Trump was like,
"Get me Maury Povich."
[ Laughter ]
"Two things. Run with me.
Number two, prove that
Eric is not my son.
I'm not the father. I'm not.
You all don't know me."
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of running
for president,
I read that Mike Pence's
presidential campaign
is more than $600,000 in debt.
Yeah, instead of a plane,
he and his staff get around
on a five-person tandem bike.
[ Laughter ]
I knew Pence
was in money trouble
when he changed his campaign
slogan to "Mike Pence,
the Rite Aid
of Republican candidates."
Yeah, that's when I knew.
-Yeah.
-Hey, I saw that NBC News
is going to host
the third Republican
primary debate.
And since the debate
is on NBC,
all the moderators
will press a button
and spin their chairs around
when they hear
something they like.
[ Laughter ]
Switching gears,
National Geographic is releasing
a "Top Gun"-inspired docu series
that will follow the journeys of
students at a Navy pilot school.
Yeah, that's a formula
for a hit.
"Top Gun" minus Tom Cruise
plus school. Awesome.
[ Laughter ]
Well, guys, it is Monday.
I thought it would be helpful
to say goodbye to everything
from the past week
and say hello to everything
that's coming up.
It's time for "Goodbye, Hello."
-♪ Goodbye, hello ♪
[ Applause ]
-Goodbye,
New York Comic-Con and hello,
Times Square Elmo
re-establishing
dominance over the city.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Goodbye, Airbnb
allowing rentals in New York,
and hello,
paying 2 grand a night
to sleep in the employee
break room at Gray's Papaya.
[ Laughter ]
Goodbye, quality,
affordable meals from Chipotle
after you raised
your prices, and hello,
Chipotle being where you now
take your spouse
for your 20th anniversary.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Goodbye, hidden junk fees
recently outlawed
by President Biden,
and hello, seeing everyone's
junk on the number-one
streaming show
"Naked Attraction."
[ Applause ]
And finally, goodbye, Rite Aid
for declaring bankruptcy
on all 2,100 stores.
Hello, 2,100 brand-new locations
of Spirit Halloween.
[ Cheers and applause ]
When you move out,
they move in.
-♪ Goodbye, hello ♪
-Thank you very much.
You guys see this? Ferrari
is now letting customers
in the U.S. buy their cars
with cryptocurrency.
It's perfect.
Now you can make two bad
financial decisions at once.
[ Laughter ]
Congratulations.
Yep. Crypto and your Ferrari.
Two things no one wants
to hear you talk about.
Meanwhile, Kia will continue
to accept payment
in Chuck E. Cheese tickets.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
-And finally, I heard
that United Airlines
is bringing back their boarding
process of travelers
with window seats
going first,
then middle seats,
and then aisle seats,
while Southwest will continue
their official boarding process,
every man for themselves.
We have a great show.